♪ ♪ ♪
- Jean McEwen était le peintre
de la couleur et de la texture,
un grand artiste canadien
qui peignait avec ses mains
et ses doigts.
SYLVIE LACERTE, conservatrice
invitée Musée beaux-arts de Mtl
- C'est un peintre qui a exploré
vraiment la surface du tableau,
la couleur, les textures.
Il était un maître dans l'art
de peindre avec ses mains.
Il disait qu'il passait de
la main à la couleur, donc...
et on dit même qu'on peut voir
ses empreintes digitales
sur certains des tableaux.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Musée des beaux-arts
a voulu rendre hommage à
ce Montréalais un peu tombé
dans l'oubli depuis sa mort,
il y a 20 ans, alors qu'il était
connu et apprécié par le public
et ses pairs de son vivant.
Il a été influencé par
Borduas et était aussi
l'ami de Jean-Paul Riopelle,
mais il n'a pas signé
le manifeste du Refus global.
- Très rapidement, il a trouvé
sa voie, ni plus ni moins,
et les automatistes, eux,
avaient une peinture qui était
beaucoup plus gestuelle, on sent
le geste dans la peinture,
ce que McEwen ne voulait pas
faire. Lui, il voulait vraiment
explorer la surface du tableau,
la couleur en tant que telle,
la texture, mais sans faire
de gestes.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Jean McEwen était membre
de l'Association des artistes
non figuratifs de Montréal.
Il excellait aussi dans l'art
de l'aquarelle et la poésie,
avec cette série d'aquarelles
illustrées de poèmes composés
pour sa femme.
Sa première exposition
s'est tenue en 1949 au Musée
des beaux-arts de Montréal.
Il a aussi exposé au Brésil,
aux États-Unis, en Angleterre
et au Japon.
- Il disait même souvent :
"Moi, je fais toujours le même
tableau." Et il n'en était pas
gêné non plus, parce qu'il
sentait qu'il avait toujours
quelque chose à explorer,
à approfondir dans le type
de travail qu'il faisait.
Un peintre fidèle
à ses convictions, à son crédo,
ni plus ni moins.
- Un magnifique artiste
à découvrir ou à redécouvrir.
Ici Catherine François, Radio-Canada, Montréal